I've written a book now it's very
different I mean because it's very
truthful and honest Bonnie Bartlett's
new Memoir middle of the rainbow dives
into her 72-year marriage to Boy Meets
World Star William Daniels and in it she
reveals the two once had an open
marriage we're lucky to have each other
very few marriages are as long and are
still going you know Bonnie and William
tied the knot in 1951 and in the book
she recalls how things were different in
the early years writing quote I guess it
was a little bit of an open marriage at
first it was at a time in New York when
there was a lot of sex and a lot of
people doing all kinds of things you
know very free but for Bonnie the
situation was hard because she says
there was a lot of pain connected to any
extramarital Affairs quote it was very
painful for the both of us but in
retrospect as the pair celebrates over
72 years of marriage Bonnie reflects on
those tougher times and says it was
quote something we had to go go through
we met very young
and we met we were both liked each
other's Talent
as well as each other's person so then
over the all the years that just
develops it changes Bonnie reveals in
the late 1950s she had an affair that
lasted a few months with another actor
but she insists she never wanted to
leave her husband quote I never felt
guilty because I never felt tied to
Fidelity and neither did Bill however
when William stepped out of the marriage
in the 1970s it left her emotionally
wrecked and she says she could no longer
tolerate any kind of open marriage
through it all the pair prioritized
their love and moved forward we've been
happy together and sad together and
somehow stayed together for seven
decades I can't imagine being with
anybody else but her
well I could but anyway
ET spoke with the lovebirds at their
home in October where they opened up
about their long-lasting marriage and
the secret to their success if you
respect the other person and really
deeply like them
that's what lasts do you know if you
really like each other
and if you really respect each other let
each other live their own life that's
very important in other words there's a
life apart and there's a life together
yeah but you gotta have both
you got to have both
you can't
live all those years together like this
[Music]